I'm here to advise you that we now have
a confirmed case of the 2019 novel novel
coronavirus in Victoria the first case
in Australia it's important to stress
that there is no cause for alarm to the
community the patient is isolated and
his undergoing treatment and we do not
have any further suspected cases at this
stage the patient is a gentleman in his
50s he's a Chinese national he's in a
stable condition with a respiratory
illness at the Monash Medical Centre in
Clayton and he was confirmed as positive
after a series of tests earlier this
morning what I can advise you is that
the gentleman has been in the city of
Wuhan in China for the past two weeks
prior to the onset of his illness and he
arrived in Melbourne on an early morning
flight on the 19th of January it's
important to stress that our health
services are very strict protocols that
apply in cases of suspected infectious
diseases and in this particular case the
gentleman and the family did everything
right